こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆さま、スマホよく電池無くなりませんか？
外出先とかでスマホの電池が切れた時皆さんはどうするかと言いますと
モバイルバッテリーを使います
コードを入れてこうやってスマホを充電すると思うんですけども
最近このモバイルバッテリーっていうのもやっぱり”大容量”モバイルバッテリーていうの流行ってるじゃないですか
やっぱ何事もね容量が大きい方がいいんすよ
結局モバイルバッテリーが大容量だったら充電も何回もできるし
長い時間充電できるんですけど　も！
私はこんなんじゃ満足しないぞ！
へぃ！
私は　もっと！もっと！
大容量
もっと！もっと～～
もっと～～ごめん、ちょっとテンションが上がりすぎた
スマホ4回くらい充電できるんですけども
僕みたいなスマホヘビーユーザー
常にゲームしたり動画とか見てる僕のような人間には
4回のモバイルバッテリーだともたない！
もっと大容量のモバイルバッテリーが欲しい！
ひとまずモバイルバッテリーをたくさん準備しました
10000mAhが100個あるんで
スマホ充電回数　400回までいけます！
こんな沢山のは1人じゃ使えない！
ヘリコプター飛んでる
こんな沢山モバイルバッテリーがあってお、重
これ丸ごとこうやって1人で持ち歩くわけにもいかないし
1人で使い切ることはないと思うので
みんなに電力を配ろう
みんなのスマホを充電させよう
僕1人だと大容量すぎて使えない
外に行って
この超大容量モバイルバッテリーがあれば
僕以外の人もみんな誰でも充電できるんじゃねーかと思いまして
*パチパチ*
外でスマホやってるとやっぱ皆充電切れると思うので
やっぱ大容量って素晴らしいですよ
僕だけじゃなく他の皆にも分け与えることができますから
はたして人は来るのでしょうか
では行こう！
*喘ぎ中*
ここら辺スマホで遊んでる人多いんで
かなり大勢の人を救えるのではないでしょうか
ふにゃふにゃだ～
はい、や～～
え、どう？
待って~
ちょっと待w
それは厳しいそれは厳しい
*ひゅ～～ん*
色んな人に
幸せをあげたいな
やるか
ケーブルをこっから外に出します
これでいつでも充電できます
*笑*
男　性：充電させてもらっていいですか？
はじめ：どうぞどうぞ
やったー
女　子：はじめしゃちょー
はじめ：はい
イェーイ
女子：真ん中の充電器持っててくださいスマホが落ちそうなので
はじめ：はい
女子：ありがとうございます
はじめ：皆さん充電できました？
女子：できましたー
女　子：ありがとうございま～す
はじめ：いえ、こちらこそ
帰りますか
もう充電器も切れちゃったんで
もう帰ります今日は。
いやでも良かった
？？？：充電してーなー
？？？：おっ充電できんじゃん
？？？：は？充電できねぇじゃなぇか
？？？：なんでだよ
うわぁぁ
意外と評判良く結構みんな使ってくれました
本当にありがとうございます！
で、今回のこの動画
大容量をテーマに動画を作ってみました
ソフトバンクではですね月々5GBのプランになんと
1000円、たったの1000円プラスするだけで
月々なんと20GBも使える超お得な大容量プランに変更することができます
まじでお得ですよ
今ならなんと25歳以下の人だったら
毎月1000円の割引なサービスが受けられます
僕もぎりぎり受けられます
（24歳、○○です。）
あの僕ですねめちゃくちゃ通信制限にかかっちゃう人なんですよ
ちょっと若いうちにこのプランは是非入っておくべきかなと僕も思いました
20GBもあればね多分月々速度制限を気にせずスマホを利用できると思うので
是非皆さん入ってみてください
大容量いいっすよ
ねっ